si les villes ne connaissent pas de
zones blanches zones où l'accès à
internet est difficile voire impossible
pour les opérations qui demande du haut
débit
il n'en va pas de même de certaines
zones rurales où les opérateurs privés
sont beaucoup moins intéressé à investir
ce sont donc les collectivités locales
qui doivent pallier à ces manques dont
le conseil départemental du loiret nous
nous sommes fixé clairement deux
objectifs d'ici fin 2020 haut débit de
qualité pour l'ensemble des lots
arrêtent un haut débit de qualité ça
veut dire au moins huit mégalithes et
d'ici 2025 la fibre généralisé sur
l'ensemble du territoire
un déploiement attendu avec impatience
dans la toute nouvelle commune qui
autour de malesherbes vient de regrouper
cette autre ancienne commune
le regroupement lui-même fonctionne
plutôt bien après ce qui nous posait
souci c'est les échanges de données
entre communes déléguées voile entre les
communes déléguées et puis le siège de
la commune nouvelle est donc là tout ce
qui est dématérialisation des documents
transmission sous préfecture nous posent
des soucis puisque à l'heure actuelle
avec les débits que nous avons nous ne
pouvons pas faire toutes ces opérations
comme nos citoyens nos concitoyens est
en effet dans la famille vives par
exemple la connexion internet ici est
très très compliqué on a moins d'un méga
de connexion internet et pour atteindre
pour atteindre quel que soit le site où
on a vraiment beaucoup de mal d'autant
qu'ici dans cette famille on est 5,5
potentiellement avoir besoin d'avoir
accès à l'internet avec des adolescents
avec et là ça devient vraiment vraiment
vraiment compliqué pour pour pour surfer
pour aller chercher tes mails pour
écouter la musique et c'est là
qu'intervient une nouvelle technologie
mise en oeuvre par le département
le très haut débit radio nous avons
offert aux petits qui arrive sur le mât
de ma vie' et on diffuse ensuite un
signal 4g dans une bande de fréquences
qui est totalement indépendante des
opérateurs mobiles dont qui a été
attribué par le régulateur et qui permet
d'avoir une fréquence dédiée pour
l'aménagement du territoire et donc
bastien vivès fini de brancher sa
parabole puis tente de se connecter à
une plate forme d'image en ligne et
cette fois à écouter c'est un marché du
premier coup là j'ai à peine eu le temps
de l'ouvrir le navigateur la
sanctionner j'ai encore du mal à 40
communes du loiret vont ainsi être
équipés à ce système et le département
prendre à sa charge le financement de
l'installation des paraboles des
particuliers par et en tennis